there's still a lot of confusion and
unknown answers
anticipation fear anxiety and excitement
as ccsd parents and the first group of
students
get ready to go back to school i want my
kids to go back asap they definitely
need some social interaction they need
they need to be around other children i
have parents telling me that their
backpacks are already packed
ready to go it's been a long time coming
eight news now is here to help and break
down everything you need to know about
sending your kids back to campus once we
have that first day and get kids back on
campus and settle in
a lot of that i know will diminish
good afternoon and thank you so much for
joining us here for this very special
edition of eight news now at 4 30.
i'm christian casadas i'm kirsten joyce
for the next 30 minutes we are going to
answer all your questions about the
return to school from cleaning to
transportation
even lunch time 8 news now reporter
kristen drummond is here now to break
down how
some valley schools have been preparing
for this big return kristen
well kirsten and christian all district
elementary schools are expected to
follow
reopening guidelines provided from the
district but it won't be a cookie-cutter
approach
you can expect some variations on each
campus as
classes move to in-person instruction
so it's just like starting a first day
of school all over again
getting ready to reopen i have to go to
my meeting clark county school district
elementary campuses work on day-to-day
logistics
figuring out staffing cleaning meal
service and scheduling for the start of
hybrid learning on march 1st
for lower elementary students making
those final tweaks of
how many kids are going to be here the
new instruction model incorporates a
rotating cohort system of a
b and c cohort a will go to school in
person on mondays and tuesdays
and do distance learning wednesday
through friday cohort b will be on
campus thursdays and fridays and do
distance learning monday through
wednesday
cohort c continues full-time distance
education
it's been exciting but also a daunting
task to do in short order
ryan lewis is principal at gerheim
elementary school he says
teachers prioritize staying with their
students and
willingly agreed to teach both online
and in-person classes to do that
a teacher could have a cohort a group of
students present and
the remaining of their students in that
class are on cohort c
but they are live streaming parts of the
day to make sure that there's direct
contact and direct instruction happening
for all kids
cameras help make that possible the
gerheim elementary school librarian
unpacked new technology equipment on
monday for educators
i think there's probably like 30 of
these a similar situation happening at
goolsby elementary school in the west
valley
teachers expect to use cameras to engage
students at home
while teaching in person we have a cart
that has a chromebook on it that's to
follow us around so if i wanted to take
my little live streaming kiddos
and bring them around the classroom i
can but the workflow differs for first
grade teacher jennifer schankberger
compared to her gerheim colleagues
so we are teaching a b and c
consecutively all at once
i have a pretty even distribution a
little bit less at home but i do have a
solid seven students at home
who are joining in every single day for
that live instruction elementary schools
making these determinations based on
what's best for their communities
goulsby's principal danny eichelberger
expects a high return rate
there's high percentages of student
return i think in second grade we have
80 percent of students returning
the assignment do we have to do it all
ccsd schools are making adjustments to
socially distant students
and follow health and safety guidelines
but superintendent dr jesus jarrow says
expect variations at each site we are
not shying away and giving school
leaders the autonomy to do different
things
dondero elementary school has a and b
markers on desks
while a second grade room at gerheim has
five tables pushed next to the wall
and one chair at each spot i've had my
ruler help measuring everything
have the dots so that they know exactly
where they need to stand to keep their
spacing
a peterson elementary school room also
placing markers on the floor to guide
students during lineup changes welcoming
the children
after nearly a year of distance
education so it's exciting to have
people back
i think we're trying to manage this
transition in the safest way possible
so how many students are in each cohort
well we have a breakdown the district
reports roughly 21 000 students in
cohort a
roughly 19 000 in cohort b and more than
51 000 will continue full-time distance
education
in cohort c all right kristin how does
that all compare with the results from
the surveys that parents initially
filled out
well kirsten it is actually a noticeable
difference from the results of the
reopening survey for lower elementary
families
now as you may recall most preferred
hybrid over distance learning
especially in the summerlin and
henderson areas by 62 to 38 percent but
as you can see from these numbers now
majority of students will be going into
cohort c
for distance education all right great
reporting thank you kristen drummond
well here is the plan from ccsd for the
remainder of the school year for all
grade levels march 22nd grade 6
9th and 12th will return to face-to-face
instruction
under the hybrid model on april 6 grades
7th
8th 10th and 11th will return also on
april 6
pre-k through grade five will return to
five days a week face-to-face
instruction
there will also be full-time distance
education still available
for parents who would rather have their
kids at home christian
well let's take you through your child's
day through the district's eyes that
starts from the moment even before they
get to school
now here's a look at procedure if your
child rides the bus
according to a new plan from the
transportation department and health
district
buses can operate at 50 capacity which
amounts to about 28 kids per bus
students will be required to wear a face
mask the entire time
and use hand sanitizer when getting on
and off
there's also uh specific steps when it
comes to
loading students take a listen drivers
will load the bus from the back to the
front
and unload from the front to the back
each student will sit in the next
available seat and follow the seat
markings
to ensure distancing between students
well students should only report to the
bus stop on assigned cohort days between
routes
bus drivers and aides will be wiping
down buses and a more thorough cleaning
will happen
every single night well for parents who
let their kids walk to school
crossing guards will be in place to make
sure students get to their destination
safely but the county needs more help
they're looking to hire more crossing
guards
by march 1st to apply you have to be at
least 18 years of age or older pass
an agility test and of course pass a
background check crossing guards are
paid
15 dollars an hour we have a link to the
application on our website eight newsnow
dot com
there's certainly been a lot of
questions sent in asking why lights were
still flashing in school zones even when
kids weren't on campus
traffic anchor nate tannenbaum says
drivers will need to get back into the
groove of paying extra attention
starting monday
all right so we sure hope you know that
any school that serves as a ccsd food
distribution site will still have the
low speed limit lights flashing at
various times a day
and that will continue even with the
younger students returned into campus
there's a message here for drivers
passing through and for anyone dropping
off the young ones of course some for
their very first
ever in school experience safety comes
first you're gonna have to slow down
and there will be extra police patrols
around schools hefty fines for violators
and that's not just speeders mom's dad's
grandparents it could also be you
if you double park or swing u-turns that
aren't allowed and you may see even more
schools turning on the flashing lights
because
with elementary school classes in
session those campuses
will no longer be food distribution
sites in fact the district is moving
those
to nearby middle or junior high campuses
we have a link
to all of those sites on our website
eightnewsnow.com buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
if there's something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8news now dot com
with safety in mind there are new
guidelines for when your child gets to
school and when it's time to pick them
up
elementary school students will be
assigned specific gates and doors for
arrival and dismissal
for students who ride the bus they'll be
dismissed last to ensure that buses come
after the bell a reminder parents and
guardians will not be allowed on school
campus to wait this is to make sure that
crowding is kept to a minimum
okay so it's the middle of the day and
your kids have made it to lunch time now
this is what
it will look like according to the
ccsd's plan classes will be released to
a multi-purpose room
one at a time students are not required
to take a lunch and will report back
to their classroom when they're finished
eating now if your child's school is
opting for students to eat in the
classroom
tables or desks will be required to be
sanitized immediately after
another note universal free breakfast
will continue for the remainder of the
school year
for those doing distance learning you'll
still be able to pick up your meal
like nate mentioned earlier it will just
be at a middle or high school location
right now
to find the nearest food distribution to
you visit the website
ccsd nutrislice.com
just as a general rule students and
staff will be encouraged to wash their
hands or use hand sanitizer particularly
after coughing or sneezing
before and after eating after being
exposed to high-touch areas like
doorknobs computers handrails
etc and of course after using the
restroom now when it comes to bathroom
protocol
students will go individually and each
class or grade will have a designated
bathroom when it comes to a health and
safety plan ccsd is reinforcing the
following rules
students and employees will wear face
coverings at all times except when
eating or drinking or during
vigorous physical activity for health
services there are three points of
service for student
now the first is the classroom where
minor first aid can be given
staff have been trained by the school
nurse to perform necessary duties
the second point is the health office or
well room and that's for needs that
cannot be addressed in the classroom
and it even goes a step further the
final point of service includes the
establishment of a sick room or an
area for students with possible covid 19
symptoms separate from the health office
the management of mild to severe illness
including students with fever
or signs and symptoms covid19 must be
handled
in the sick room to prevent possible
cross-exposure risks
with healthy students and staff if a
student is sent to the sick room the
school's administration will follow
student exposure protocol
and a parent or guardian will then be
contacted
keeping everyone safe is of course the
main priority disinfection and cleaning
will occur
thoroughly and frequently in several
stages daily cleaning where custodial
staff will wipe down classrooms and
sanitize restrooms enhanced cleaning
we'll cover wiping down electronics and
high touch areas
and if there is a positive covet case
the process gets a little more intensive
a facilities management disinfecting
cleaning crew will be dispatched to the
campus to perform
a disinfection cleaning which includes
the use of an electrostatic sprayer
throughout the entire site additional
deep clean protocols will be followed
for that campus in compliance with cdc
recommendations more cleanings will
happen
after hours night crews will work on
other cleaning vacuuming and
disinfecting
well schools will be limiting who's
allowed to be on campus to only those
who are essential to school or district
activities
or those who make an appointment all
visitors should complete a questionnaire
and symptom self-check form wear a
visible badge or a sticker that proves
that you were screened and of course
wear
a face mask at all times along with a
plan to get students back to the
classroom we're also learning more about
when student athletes can get back on
the court and field of course let's pull
in sports director chris matthews with
that hey chris
well thank you very much yeah with the
governor giving the thumbs up and
superintendent dr jesus
jarrah's blessing high school sports
will be back this spring
now here's the plan spring sports
practices begin in early april for a
variety of boys and girls sports with
competition beginning april 16th
for the intramural fall sports that had
to be adjusted because of covid
football will be back but not with games
full contact competition within each
school
basically a spring football practice to
get ready for the 2021 season
other fall intramural sports will take
place in may both boys and girls
they've staggered the sport so that
students aren't forced to choose a
single sport
and of course no fans allowed and
coaches and other adults will have to
test negative before all activities
hey and that's fine they're just
grateful to be back there's some very
good baseball players that that would
have
that played two years at jv baseball
that that potentially could have not
you know put on a varsity uniform and
played a varsity game that that are
college
athletes during the fall to keep myself
and the boys motivated
but you know we kept working and now
we have to go to play a season so you
know everyone's ready and
it's a great feeling oh it must be a
great feeling certainly now the kids
will have a chance to showcase those
skills
as college recruiters can now look to
las vegas once again
activities also like theater band drill
teams also expected to return
kirsten great news thanks so much this
week dr jarrah had a one-on-one with
parents to answer
questions about getting back to school
and the timeline moving forward one
particularly vocal group
was parents of seniors they want to know
how their students will be celebrated
when it comes to things like graduation
dr jarrah says for now plans remain
fluid
one of the things that we've learned
from cobalt you've got to be flexible so
one of the things that now when the
governor's restriction
because we didn't have any venues now we
do there's potential of opportunities
where we're looking at now
to you know have you obviously have an
increase in graduation class size
um that we can celebrate them so we're
going to have to go back and retool
and revisit the entire thing
well as of now dr jarrah says he's
largely taking cues from the governor
and
county covid restrictions before any
large celebration or gathering
is set in stone kirsten dr jarrar was
also asked about summer school as some
parents are concerned about their
students
falling behind and this is what he had
to say about that
one of the things recommendations from
the
from the stimulus money that's coming
eventually to get to to get to us
is that there is some some kind of
accelerated mechanism for
children whether it's summer school
or extended year whatever we want to
call it we are
early conversations around that
dr jara says as conversations progress
the district will let parents know
sooner rather than later
so they can make plans of course for
their children
in just a few minutes the first
in-person school board meeting in months
will begin
groups of parents who want to push up
that timeline for kids to be back in the
classroom planning to testify
in person they've gathered outside that
meeting being held at the las vegas
academy of the arts
we will have the latest from parents and
trustees on air and online with a live
report from sasha loftis
christian well with just four days to go
we will continue to bring you all the
latest updates here on air and of course
on eight news now dot com now if there's
anything we may have missed
ccsd has a highly detailed list of
protocols and procedures
on reconnect.ccsd.org
very important website right there yeah
there is so much to digest so
go check out that website and ours as
well thanks so much for watching this
special back to school edition of 8 news
now at 4 we're always on at 8newsnow.com
and our app along with facebook and
twitter
[Music]